allora quello che vedete alle mie spalle
è un articolo uscito su un quotidiano
recentemente che come molti altri prima
vuole farci riflettere su una
problematica molto attuale però della
quale ancora non si stiamo soffermando
abbastanza il mio obiettivo oggi è
quello di rendervi consapevoli di cosa
effettivamente sta succedendo e di cosa
succederebbe se in futuro le ha più
scomparissero bene dovete sapere che
negli ultimi 20 anni c'è stata una vera
e propria moria delle api a casa di
cambiamenti climatici a causa di
pesticidi delle monocolture intensive le
api hanno subito una vera e propria
moria
basti pensare che solo nell'unione
europea
gli alveari sono diminuiti del 50 per
cento
questo non rappresenta solo un fattore
economico infatti il valore
dell'impollinazione di queste api è pari
a 265 miliardi di dollari all'anno
ma il vero problema è che il 70 per
cento del cibo e dei prodotti che
mangiamo ogni giorno veniva direttamente
dall impollinazione di questi insetti e
tutto il cibo che diamo per scontato
quindi come per esempio i pomodori
oppure allargandoci una scala più
generale come per esempio i broccoli le
patate le carote le mele le pere
tutto ciò scomparirebbe per darvi un
esempio più concreto e per farvi capire
cosa questo comporterebbe nel quotidiano
ho deciso di fare una foto o una cena
che mi sono preparato a due sere fa
ovviamente non mi tratti così bene tutte
le sere per ora per farvi capire cosa
avrei mangiato
se le api non fossero esistite una
tristissima pasta in bianco
bene vi starete chiedendo
beh ci saranno delle soluzioni si sarà
già stato fatto qualcosa per ovviare a
questo problema
beh se le soluzioni per ora sono
trasportare da una parte all'altra del
paese
interi alveari per andarli a fare
impollinare con le aree dove ormai le
api sono scomparse
in tutto ciò a farmi morire la metà
durante il trasporto o se addirittura ci
immaginiamo già uno scenario in cui le
api non esisteranno più
e quindi stiamo cercando delle soluzioni
come api robot che possano addirittura
svolgere il lavoro che svolgono le api
beh signori non abbiamo capito a cosa
sono incontrano un incontro esempi
positivi invece sono per esempio con
libera più cultura urbana l'apicoltura
urbana significa allevare le app in
città perché in città dove c'è lo smog
beh in realtà oggi le campagne a causa
dei pesticidi delle monocolture
intensive rappresentano un habitat molto
più sfavorevole rispetto a quello della
città e abbiamo anche degli esempi molto
positivi in italia finalmente per
esempio il primo è stato il progetto
urbis a torino e il progetto rubis vuole
cercare di far partecipare i cittadini
ad allevare le api sui propri balconi o
sennò spostandoci ancora più vicino a
milano col progetto ni factory di
francesco faccin che permette ai bambini
di osservare la clip da vicino in
sicurezza e agli agricoltori di poter
insegnare ai bambini come in questo caso
sta facendo mauro vacca che un
apicoltore molto attivo a milano
l'importanza che hanno le api entrambi
questi esempi hanno un punto comune
fondamentale che è l'educazione solo
attraverso l'educazione infatti possiamo
affrontare questo problema in maniera
sostenibile consapevolizza amici
a proposito di educazione io per motivi
di studio per interessi verso la cultura
e la lingua cinese come ha detto
francois prima sono state in cina
l'ultimo anno e mezzo è proprio in cina
mi sono scontrata con una realtà
paradossale
nonostante la cina è il primo produttore
mondiale di miele di export e di
apicoltura a causa dell'inquinamento
altissimo in cina e dello sviluppo
frenetico delle città
le api sono diminuite drasticamente se
in città
il problema non è assolutamente
percepito nelle campagne lo è molto
sentito
tant'è che in alcune regioni della cina
gli apicoltori migrano nelle aree dove
le api vivono bene per proteggerlo
salvaguardarle i figli degli apicoltori
però non vedendo futuro nel lavoro dei
loro padri
decidono di migrare nelle città in cerca
di un lavoro che possa dare più
opportunità in questo modo gli
apicoltori rimangono da soli e non hanno
modo di trasmettere con la passione e
quelle tecniche del proprio lavoro come
vorrebbero fare
pensate che in alcune regioni le api
sono addirittura scomparse e gli uomini
hanno preso il posto delle api questo
vuol dire che intere comunità
interi popoli degli agricoltori ogni
giorno dalla mattina alla sera con un
bastone di bambù impollinano fiore per
fiore albero per albero correndo tra
l'altro dei rischi allucinanti perché
bambini anziani adulti si arrampicano su
questi alberi dalla mattina alla sera
chiaramente la situazione insostenibile
se da un punto di vista fisico ma
soprattutto economico per farvi per
farvi un confronto infatti se uno sciame
impallina 200 alberi al giorno un uomo
ape e in pollina massimo 10 e se
ragioniamo ad alveare un superorganismo
ape ecco questo è in grado di visitare
225.000 fiori al giorno quindi capite
anche voi che per quanto ci possiamo
sforzare non riusciremo mai a imitare
latte
sul nodo bene a questo punto mi sono
resa conto dell'urgenza del bisogno di
fare qualcosa e ho iniziato a chiedermi
ma io cosa posso fare
sono in un contesto che non conosco non
ho nessun contatto
se cerco internet sulle apicoltori uno
esce fuori niente
in un anno l'unica pecca ho visto
probabilmente sarà stata un ape piaggio
cosa posso fare e poi mi sono iniziate a
chiedere alla vera perché non provare
introdurre un modello educativo nel
sistema cinese e perché non cercare di
sensibilizzare sul ruolo dell'apicoltore
e l'importanza delle api prima di tutto
allora ho dovuto capire cosa posso
insegnare e sono arrivata alla
definizione di tre argomenti
grazie all'aiuto degli apicoltori che
avevo conosciuto anche a milano ea tutti
i seminari e libri che avevo letto
sull'argomento a chi insegnarlo
ho trovato una grande opportunità nelle
scuole elementari cinese
prima di tutto perché sono tantissime e
poi perché solo partendo dalle
generazioni future
potremmo arrivare a un cambiamento
effettivo come insegnarlo attraverso la
progettazione di tre workshop ciascun
workshop legato a ciascun argomento che
avevo selezionato e fondamentalmente
questi workshop erano divisi in una
parte dedicata alla didattica e una
parte con attività creative di gioco
oppure produzione di oggetti insieme la
cosa ancora più difficile è stata
trovare una scuola e convincere gli
insegnanti a introdurre in un programma
educativo che era già stato fissato un
argomento della quale nessuno sapeva
niente e addirittura quindi nessuno dava
importanza alla fine sono riuscita a
trovare una scuola e sono andato in
questa scuola a testare tutti gli
strumenti e materiali che avevo
progettato e i bambini per la prima
volta si sono affacciati a questi
strumenti queste metodologie
che non avevano mai visto ad esempio che
ho fatto testare le pettorine che mi
sono servite per fare per fargli
interpretare meglio il ruolo della per
farli sentire più a proprio agio
oppure le carte della più per aie che mi
sono servite per generare un gioco di
performance in cui divisi per ruoli
dovevano interpretare il tipo di ruolo
della pro x aia che le aveva assegnato
un altro aspetto fondamentale è stato
coinvolgere l'apicoltore perché come ci
siamo detti prima gli apicoltori sono
molto isolati e non hanno l'opportunità
di parlare ai propri figli di insegnare
di trasmettere e pensate che questo
apicoltore mia stato addirittura vietato
di chiamarlo mi dicevano ah non verrà
mai lascia perdere
cosa non basato disturbi a fare io gli
ho mandato un messaggino
pensate che ha speso due giorni di
viaggio per venire a parlare neanche
venti minuti a questi bambini e voi non
potete immaginare la gratitudine la
compassione che aveva questa persona
mentre parlava bambini li faceva vedere
i suoi strumenti e gli racconta il
proprio lavoro e dall'altra parte i
bambini i bambini erano molto
affascinati da questa figura che non
avevano mai visto continuavano a fargli
domande continuano a toccare a muoversi
erano molto entusiasti
potrei continuare ancora per ore a farvi
vedere immagini e raccontarvi cosa è
successo ma penso che il modo migliore
per raccontarlo se attraverso un video
che mostra un po l'esperienza che ho
trascorso con loro
grazie
alla fine del progetto abbiamo
partecipato a un mercatino di fine anno
che tutte le scuole elementari in cina
organizzano e questo mercatino è stato
un momento fondamentale per me prima di
tutto per capire il valore e l'impatto
che aveva avuto il progetto dall'inizio
fino a quel momento lì dal punto di
vista dei bambini dal punto di vista dei
genitori delle insegnanti e
dell'apicoltore e secondo perché a
questo mercatino partecipavano circa 700
persone
quindi c'era una bella opportunità per
accogliere i loro feedback e tutto il
giorno i bambini sono stati a parlare
educare la gente delle api
dell'importanza delle api
i genitori li guardavano tutti contenti
per erano entusiasti di questo progetto
e pensate che l'apicoltore è riuscito a
vendere tutti i prodotti che aveva
portato quel giorno probabilmente non ha
mai venduto così tanti mieli in un
giorno in tutta la sua vita tant'è che
ad essere ancora in contatto con i
genitori e addirittura la scuola sta
organizzando una gita per i bambini per
andare a trovare l'apicoltore vicino a
shanghai tutti gli strumenti tutti i
materiali le elezioni tutto quello che
ho utilizzato per fare i tre workshop li
ha raccolti in un manuale per gli
insegnanti per dargli la possibilità di
riutilizzarlo oppure di riproporre
questo workshop in futuro in altre
scuole elementari oppure in altre con
altre classi e alla fine questa
esperienza è stata fantastica per me
prima di tutto mi hanno cambiato perché
appena tornato in italia ha voluto
subito rifare lo stesso workshop con le
scuole media milano secondo perché
mangio un sacco di miele adesso è anche
ha cambiato i bambini infatti dopo
qualche mese mi ha chiamato l'insegnante
ha detto
oggi aiutato nate in classe e i bambini
che ora non hanno più paura della per ci
sono fiondati verso la te e con la mano
l'hanno riaccompagnata fuori dalla
finestra e questo alla fine di tutto per
degli albi che secondo me possiamo
ognuno di noi può dare un contributo
seppur piccolo per risolvere questo
problema
quindi ora voglio farvi una domanda la
prossima volta che vedrete un app e non
una vespa una per ha scarcerato e via
all e di rete grazie grazie